[Music]
kubernetes gets an application running
in a cluster by applying a configuration
file that we create let's say we've
built an application for running a
web-based travel business we're
passionate about delivering the best
travel experiences to our users from
flights to recommended tours to the
perfect hotel our developers
containerized our application and we're
ready to deploy the containers to
kubernetes we started by creating the
deployment configuration file for our
application the configuration describes
the application and the required
kubernetes objects in kubernetes
application containers are encapsulated
into a pod kubernetes is responsible for
creating and managing pods of containers
connecting them to the network and the
rest of the environment we're assuming
that all of the software to run our
application in kubernetes is
encapsulated in a single pot we're going
to use the cube control CLI command to
apply the configuration file each of our
drones is connected directly to a pod in
the kubernetes cluster our drones watch
kubernetes for changes and react to
those changes because our deployment
creates a new pod one of our drones
takes off our app pod is airborne
you